هذه هي المره الاولى التي استطيع ان ابتسم
فيها خلال الساعات الاربعه وعشرين الماضيه
كانت صعبه للغايه
وانا سعيد
ومسرور لاننا هنا جميعا نشعر بالامان بعد
ان خرجنا من الخرطوم برحله طويله لكننا
انجزنا هذا الامر سويه
تعرضنا لبعض عمليات القصف اثناء رحلتنا
لكن لكن انه الامر رائع باننا وصلنا الى
بر الامان
[موسيقى]
وخاصه في ظل ظروف في القصر انني ممتن لكم
جميعا لانكم استطعتم
ان تعملوا في ظل تلك الظروف الصعبه
ووصلتم الى هنا امنين
وانني ممتن الى بعض الاشخاص بعينهم الذين
تدخلوا هو عندما كانت الحاجه تقضي بذلك
وتقدموا العون الضروري لنا جميعا ودعوني
اقول بعض الكلمات لافراد محددين دون
تسميتهم
شكرا جزيلا لجون من
لجنه الانقاذ الدوليه
ومن الصليب الاحمر فقد ساعدنا على الخروج
من الخرطوم
وقد قامت بعمل رائع
وقام بعمل رائع
فلنشكر كافه هؤلاء الذين سهلوا لنا مساله
وصول الى هذا المكان الامن
نشكره كافه السائقين الذين
سهلوا تلك المهمه وذللوا كافه الصعاب
ودون جهودهم لما كنا لنصل الى هنا
ورغم كافه الصعوبات والقياده لمسافه تزيد
عن 900 كيلومتر استطاعوا ان ينجزوا تلك
المهمه
والشكر الموصول الى هؤلاء الذين تدخلوا
عندما دعت الحاجه لذلك
واشكر على وجه التحديد شخصين
محددين
على تنظيمهما لكافه الاشياء التي كنا
نحتاجها اثناء رحلتنا
وعلى تسهيل
عمليه النقل
قدر
هذا الامم الى السودان هو تحدث وشكره خاصه
من مكانه من الخروج من الخرطوم قال بانه
نحن صرنا لمسافه 900 كلمنا من الوصول الى
منطقه اسمها بالمنطقه الامنه لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات